Mor Eini, thank you
for joining me on my show.
How are you?
I'm very good.
Thank you very much for inviting me.
So actually, you're I think
my first guest
that's talking from Europe
right now, right?
Yes. At the moment I'm based in Berlin.
Based in Berlin.
Okay. Well, that's quite
an interesting experience
to be there during covid
even though I believe that Berlin
actually managed pretty well
right from the get go, right?
Mm hmm. Definitely.
Actually, here it feels like
we're almost back to the old normal.
Really? Okay.
Well that's very different
from my usual base,
which is either in California
or Tel Aviv.
Both these places right now.
But this will, it'll take a few weeks
until we publish this.
So, let's hope that
everywhere will be great.
Mor, you're based in Berlin.
You're working for APX
strategy and partnerships
one of the leading early stage
venture capitals and accelerators.
And you're running
relationships and strategy.
So, talk to me a little bit about
what you're doing at APX,
how you even got to Berlin,
and then I'd love to go
a little higher, 30,000 feet in the air
and talk about the European ecosystem
for startups.
So actually you ask one question,
but with like 10 different questions.
100%. I love doing that.
I will try, as a good Israeli,
I will try to answer all your question
and provide the answers
that actually I wanna give
and information that I wanna give.
So, let's see how it works.
If I forgot anything, just let me know.
Sounds great.
What is APX in general?
APX is a joint venture of Axel Springer,
which is the biggest
European media publisher actually.
Not many people know,
and to our Israeli audience,
they actually bought ...
Oh, wow.
Yes.
So of course
there is an Israeli connection.
Actually, it's a very well known
German company.
It always supports Israel
since long long time ago.
And together with Porsche,
which is the German automotive OEM
luxury sports car.
And actually, I started there
while I was managing
their partnership with Facebook
which is, I would say,
quite an interesting partnership.
What is that partnership? How is Facebook connecting to
the startup ecosystem over there?
So actually Facebook has this kind of like
it's called the Facebook accelerator.
It exists all over Europe
and also in Israel, in Berlin,
or in Germany or in ...
I don't know how we wanna call it,
we were their local partners.
So, actually the aim was to see
how we can help Facebook
integrate their technologies
into startups.
So, we’re not talking here about ads
or managing campaign ads,
but actually more of like
a bit more well-advanced technologies
like AR, VR, messenger, and AI.
So, we had quite an interesting journey.
It was twelve weeks working
with C-Levels of I would say
early stage startups,
but not that early.
So, that was what I was doing
for the last six months.
And then recently,
I stayed and shifted my position
a little bit towards
strategic partnership and growth.
And just to make it, keep it simple
So basically, my job is to understand
how I position APX, not only Europe wise
as the leading early stage investor,
but also in Israel and other ecosystems.
And in parallel to that,
to create business opportunities
for our portfolio that is currently
with over 50 companies
from actually, all over the world.
That's awesome. Okay.
So what does that mean,
how do you go about
and taking a VC or an accelerator,
and taking it from Europe
and trying to get it based in Israel
and trying to get in on the good deals
and become a well-known brand
so that Israeli start-ups,
instead of going to some of the other
well-known VCs,
they would consider going to APX
for their seed or series A?
If you have the answers,
please let me know.
Because that's actually
what I'm trying to do.
But in a nutshell,
maybe it's also connected to who I am
and where I'm coming from.
So, I'm originally Israeli.
Was born and raised in Israel.
Was working quite a lot
in the Israeli ecosystem.
You were working with mobility, right?
Yes. I started my career
with EcoMotion,
which is the biggest smart mobility
community in Israel.
And later on, I worked for Hubraum
which is the seed investment vehicle
of Deutsche Telekom.
So, I guess I always had
a German kind of like bug inside of me.
And then after, yeah
after those positions, I decided
okay, it's about time to see
what else out there,
outside of the Israeli ecosystem bubble
which is very comfortable.
But I felt
it was too comfortable for me.
And I believe
in actually creating value.
I mean, I'm in my core,
I'm a community manager.
That's how I started.
And I believe
that to create a fruitful ecosystem or
to create a really meaningful community,
you need to provide value
not only to the members,
but also to people that are trying to see
how they can partner with the community.
And that's exactly
how I see this position as well.
I feel like okay it's, APX,
it's a joint venture
of two well-known names
I would say
not only in the German ecosystem,
but in the worldwide ecosystem
if I can call it that way.
But what makes us different
than other VCs or other programs
that are out there,
and it's actually the value
that we can provide to the companies.
And I think that,
although we have this corona crisis
and it might be more challenging
to raise money,
but good companies will approach VCs
that not only can give them the money,
but can also give them the connection.
And the, I would say,
the unique selling point.
It can be connections.
It can be, I don't know,
good advice or feedback or support,
helping them to get new customers.
And that's what I'm trying to do
in the position
because we do provide money,
but what else do we provide?
Amazing. So I'm fairly comfortable
within the Silicon Valley ecosystem,
the Tel Aviv ecosystem
in terms of how startups operate
and the different stages
that they go through.
I'm very excited to go
on that journey myself pretty soon
in both fields.
But I know nothing about
the European ecosystem,
and obviously some say
that Israel is part of Europe,
but the real European ecosystem
and Germany and in Berlin
and the places that you get to work at,
how do startups operate there?
Is it different than in Palo Alto
or Tel Aviv?
Is there a different mindset?
Are the investment stages the same?
Talk to me a little bit about that.
So first of all, when you say Europe,
I mean, it's pretty challenging
to say Europe
and then try to generalize it
because you can't.
Yeah. I'm sure.
Even in Germany,
the Berlin ecosystem
doesn't look like the ecosystem
in Munich or in Frankfurt.
So maybe, if we will,
that's why when I talk to startups
and they're like,
"Yeah, we see Europe is
our next destination."
I'm like, "Okay, what is Europe?
Is it UK?
Is it France?
Is it the Netherlands?
Maybe we're talking about Poland"
Is it mostly cultural norms
or professional norms that are different?
I think it's all together,
but one thing I can say that I think
that if you manage to conquer Germany
in a way, you as a startup
have a good reputation
because Germany is well known
to being a bit of a tough market here
I think not only for foreign startups,
but also, for German startups themself.
I will now, maybe very much generalize it
just for the sake of the conversation,
but it goes a bit deeper than that.
But Germans, if I would say
put it like that, compared to Israelis,
are less tend to take risks.
And if a small company from Israel
come and say, knock on the door and say,
"Hey, hello.
We have this great technology.
We've been to 8200.
I'm sure you heard about us.
You know, we're going to revolutionize
the way that you are protecting your data.
Let me show you how we do it."
So, don't be surprised if they say,
if they're very polite and say,
"Thank you, but we don't need you
at the moment."
Or they don't even bother
to answer the e-mail.
So, I think what's really important
in Germany, is actually to make sure
that when you come here,
you know exactly what is it
that you wanna get.
You are pretty stable finance-wise,
but also have the capacity
to actually deliver what it is
that you promise.
And I know that in the Israel ecosystem,
we always say,
"Of course, we can do it.
In 14 days, you will have it."
But when you come here,
you can't say 14 days
and then deliver it in six months.
Yeah.
It doesn't work like that.
And you need to come
when you have ...
When you have invoices.
When you are like,
Okay, that's what I was doing so far.
Now, here, that's how I see
how I can optimize that
or help you to achieve that.
Don't try to find
how you are going to change
the entire structure
because Germans also don’t like changes.
For years, their economy's working.
The industry is moving.
You can't come there
and promise them something
that you both know
you won't be able to deliver.
So, try to be a bit modest
I would say.
And also, come prepared
that it's going to take
be a long process.
But, the minute you manage to create
this confidence,
so they will see you
as a long-term client or costumer
And actually you're going to walk
this road together for a long time.
And I guess, that's what's also different
than US.
Right. So, both in the US and in Israel,
it's also very accepted
that big corporates
are partners with startups
and they're very supportive of startups.
Not only do they have
often venture arms
to invest in startups,
but they often bring them in
and do these initial contracts
pretty leniently.
Similarly, C-level executives
in a lot of these companies
are angel investors themselves
or they sit on the boards
of startups themselves.
Is that existent
in the German ecosystem?
Do German corporates have an arm?
Do they help startups?
Do the executives invest
and sit on the boards?
Or is that different as well?
So actually
it's a very interesting question.
And I think that in Israel,
it's very small ecosystem
and it has its own rules,
but it's also a bit far away
from the headquarters.
And eventually,
when you approach this corporate,
you start with playing
in the Israeli ecosystem
but it does not promise
that you will take a core part
in what the mission or strategy
of the headquarters.
And that's what I was doing in Hubraum
in Deutsche Telekom.
I was basically
their woman on the ground
and helped to source startups
that might be potentially
strategically relevant for Hubraum.
And I can tell you,
it's super challenging.
Eventually you need to understand
what the strategy
that the corporate need,
not even now,
maybe in two, three years.
And then to understand
who within this corporate
will be able to lead you in this,
I would say,
very sometimes complicated roads
within the corporate.
And actually, that's something
that I was trying to solve here,
because I realized
that we, the Israeli ecosystem,
I think it's amazing
the way it helps and provides support
and knowledge sharing
to all the members,
all the different members
of the ecosystem.
And here in Berlin,
I felt it was a bit missing.
It's also important to say that
it's not like you cannot really compare
the Israeli ecosystem in Berlin
to the one in Silicon Valley
or in London in other places,
because it wasn't that developed.
Only in the like few last years
you can see more and more Israelis
that actually comes here
to work in startups
and to work with big companies
and big corporate.
And together with a friend and a partner,
we created here a community
for Israelis in tech and business,
and the aim was actually to create
this small Israeli ecosystem
where you create connection,
helps to network, and provide tip, advice,
or even just support to anyone who needs.
So we have more than 200 members
coming from different corporates
in Germany,
startups, governments,
Israeli companies that are based here
because, indeed,
it's very very tough sometimes
to come into this market and say,
"Hey, okay, what's next?"
And sometimes you just need
to hear a little Hebrew
and to have a little fun and have it be with friends.
But Mor why are you doing this?
Because it sounds very complicated.
It sounds tough.
It sounds like
this is a developing area that
there's a lot of,
you really have to understand
the different players.
And it's not necessarily as open yet
as in a lot of other areas.
Why are you over there instead of
being in Silicon Valley or in Tel Aviv?
It's an interesting question
and I sometimes ask myself
the same question.
What happened?
Like you could stay in Tel Aviv,
and do your thing
and everything will be fine.
And you won't have to struggle
with Germans
and with the language
and with the culture.
But I think that those
outside of comfort zone spaces
where you can grow the most.
I mean, the level of connections
and experience that I gained here
in less than three years, is tremendous.
I don't think I could ever
be able to create something like that
not only in Israel,
but in other places that are
maybe a bit more mature
than the ecosystem here.
And I think that that also gives me
an opportunity to grow
within the ecosystem
and actually to position myself
in a place that I can create new things
and initiate different projects
that actually no one saw before.
And I can say that
many of the things that I was doing
is something it's like those things
that I got from the Israeli ecosystem
and the way we work.
And it's super fun.
I feel it's like,
okay, it's a new playground.
I bring my skills,
but I also had the experience
and the opportunity to learn
and get to know other culture
which in the world of today,
I think it's something you can't learn
through computer
or with making video calls.
You actually have to be here
and understand
how this ecosystem operates
and also how different people create
different kind of businesses
and relations.
And sometimes when I'm visiting Israel,
I need to do this shift in mind.
I'm like, okay. Here, you don't cue.
You need to go from that side
or to be a bit more louder
if you wanna get what it is
that you want.
So, it's a different mindset
and it's like, for me,
amazing to get this exposure
to what I'm having here.
And also, to be this channel
when Israeli companies or people
that also want to experience,
I can be that person that say,
"Hey, you can do that
and that" because
it's something that I myself did it.
That's so so cool.
So, did covid hit the German ecosystem
the same way that it hit the other world
in terms of everybody
going to remote working
and startups having troubles
raising money?
Was it a similar thing in your area?
I would say yes and no.
I think that here,
we need to divide it
also to different aspects.
I think that the German government
was well prepared
to what is about to come.
Many startups, or many not only startups,
many companies in general
in the German industry, have
what is called ...
which is the company still exist
and the government pays 60% to 70%
of the employees' salary.
So, the companies didn't fire anyone.
People are still working.
Yes, and I think that's amazing.
So, the economy is still moving.
And I think that create
a bit less stressful situation.
I can tell you that at APX,
we actually invested
in more than five companies
during since, I would say,
corona started hit us all
in the beginning of March.
So, we continue to invest money
in startups.
We also see that, I mean,
it's not that corona hit
and then suddenly you stop everything.
Some of the process started
before that.
So, in for many of those giant companies
and big big companies,
it's not like a matter of
Okay, in a month or two,
I'm going to change my entire strategy
something that the budget and the plan
was deployed long time ago.
So, you keep moving.
Some of the companies actually said,
"Okay, we're not going to hire
new people at the moment."
But, the ecosystem is still moving.
Like everyone else,
we adapted ourself to be in an online world,
but I have to admit that last week,
I was actually in a physical event.
Wow.
Yes.
That's a little scary in my mind.
I have to
one of the things
that I was contemplating with friends
was that we're watching Netflix now.
And all of a sudden
you see in the movie
two people hugging or shaking hands.
And I'm like,
"Oh my God! Look,
no, you can't!"
There's a pandemic!"
What are you doing?"
So I think
it's a really interesting thing
that's happening now.
But Mor, do you see yourself long-term
in this relationship between
Germany and Israel?
Or is this something that, you're like,
Wow. I had this amazing five years.
Now I'm ready to go
now I'm ready to go back to Tel Aviv
or to my next country for an adventure.
So maybe I should ask you that question.
If someone would ask you like
like six months ago,
would you ever imagine
that we will have no flights?
We won't be able to leave our home.
And restaurants or bar
are going to be closed.
Would you imagine that?
So, I guess not.
And I guess that's life.
For me, it feels like,
I can plan and decide
how is it that I see my future,
or what I'm going to do in five years,
but reality prove us
that we can't plan that long.
So at the moment, I'm having fun,
and I feel that I'm being challenged
and learn new things.
And actually, I can grow here.
At some point,
I know myself,
I need to change.
And whenever I feel too comfortable,
I know that it's about time to leave.
So, when I feel like that, maybe
I will make the change.
But let's see, I guess.
Wonderful.
Mor, before we leave.
I wanna ask,
you get to see all these startups
and you get to see
these different ecosystems.
Do you notice any things that are perhaps
lagging in terms of the ecosystem
that you're in?
Some technologies
that we already consider mainstream
in different parts of the world
that are potential opportunities
for young entrepreneurs
who are considering their next steps
and maybe there's a good opportunity
in Europe or specifically in Germany?
So I think in general,
the startup material here
is a bit different than what you see
maybe I'll say in Tel Aviv
because I'm not very familiar
with what's going on in Silicon Valley.
Here, and I would be precise
and say Berlin,
because I don't wanna talk
about the rest of Germany
because as I mentioned,
it's a bit different.
Startups here
are less technology innovative,
but more of like, business model
or product innovative.
You can see a lot of consumer products.
A lot of B2C, which is actually
quite interesting.
In Israel, you can see a lot of deep tech.
So, companies that it will take them
five to seven years until we will
or very very long life cycles of sales
until you can actually see something.
And here, it's a bit different.
I mean, you can see that the big unicorns,
the German unicorns,
are marketplaces for cars
Auto Eins.
Zalando which is the German ASOS.
Get Your Guide which is marketplace
for travelling or tourism.
And it's not by accident.
I mean, you need,
that's what I'm saying that
I don't think it's a different world,
but the way technology perceived here
is a bit different
than what we see in Israel.
In Israel, we are very much used to say,
Okay, we're going to change the way
that we drive our car,
and everything is super super
technology oriented.
We're here to be different,
but you can also see the success
very fast of those products,
or the failures.
So, I would say that
I think it's a great place.
To come here after you have some,
I would say, product validation
and technology validation.
But it's not a very good place
for experimentation.
So I would recommend,
unless you are very like mobility
and then like all the OEM and tier ones,
this is a perfect place for you.
And also depends which
what is it in mobility that you are doing.
Come here when you already have
some funding, product market fit,
a bit more stability in the company,
and maybe my tip will actually be
to have someone that is physical here
although we all live in Zoom.
I think that with Germans,
it's very very important
to have someone on the ground
that you can contact with.
And if he's German and local,
it's sometimes even better.
Because although we say,
"Yeah, we are Swiss knives Israelis.
We can do everything everywhere."
It's crucial to have someone here
and if that someone speaks German,
and not only the language
but the culture,
I guess your life will be easier.
That really sounds interesting.
Mor, thank you so much for your time
again for your generosity.
Before we leave, I need three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
So, that's going to be a tricky one.
I'll do my best.
So, I would say,
Israeli.
Redhead.
And white wine.
Israeli, redhead, and white wine.
I love it.
Mor, toda raba.
Thank you very much
and best of luck with everything.
danke schön
Bye bye. Thank you.
Bye.